you've never been kissed huh no I
haven't liked that movie yeah what I
mean what if the first kiss goes down in
the Big Brother house well first I got
to give you that suspicion wall yes
because that's that's a big wall to get
through if it happens it happens
[Music]
my name is Scotty and I'm from Chicago
Illinois and why big brother Scotty oh
I'm a really really big fan my sister
got me into it back in like season seven
and then after that we got my little
sister into it and then my big brother
and like we watch it like all together
now it's it's like a I mean that this
year we won't but I think a whole big
thing there yes it's like me and my
siblings are like all about it so like
we sit there and we just like we will
like roast houseguests that's that's our
bread and butter so now it's they're
just gonna roast me probably if the
tables are gonna turn it's gonna be all
on me what I mean
eyes I'm tribute I'm Sultan tribute yeah
I know you can only tell a few people
you're going to do this the family that
you were were able to tell what was
their reaction
well at first the people like did tell
it like they thought it was a bit they
thought I was kidding there is like that
there's no way cuz like I'm the kind of
person who will like run a bit like that
and like cuz when I do something funny I
don't care what if anyone else thinks
it's funny it's a hundred percent for me
I have completely selfish humor so they
just thought like he's kind of going out
of his way for this and then by the time
they believe me they were just like like
they were like like excited they're kind
of like their face was broken excited
yeah so I mean it was totally appalled
alright going into this game you've been
a super fan for a while who are you
gonna steal tactics from who's somebody
you're gonna model your gameplay after
well my favorite player ever is Chicken
George yeah I just love how like
unassuming he was the entire time and
people just like didn't go from without
one assume he is so I kind of want to be
that same nature where people are just
gonna be like I would have to worry
about him it's kind of a nitwit but like
I also want to be able to win calm I
like I don't want to be like a useless
player like I want to be like in other
people's brains like perception wise I
want to be like a useful piece for them
that way I'm not just like there is like
dead meat okay so that's kind of what
I'm gonna go for is there any player
that you are like I will not play like
that
Joe's a hunter for San Jose they say I
don't want to be going
B I don't want to target the current HOH
immediately and then run my mouth about
it nor do I want to like call myself to
Messiah immediately and like just
pretend everyone's in my back pocket
after like days it was ridiculous not
all that smart not to follow yes this is
Big Brother 20 I know I think you big
big deal chances are a big twist is
coming yes what do you hope that twist
is ah well I'm not gonna like hope for
anything but I like my suspicions or
what I think it could be like I could
see them doing like every week it's like
simulated after a previous season like
they do like a BB sixteen week will
bring battle of lock bag or like a BB
eight week where they like have one
person be like America's player and just
stuff like that or like a BB 13 really
like be off to pair up for the week I
can see something like that happening
it's like they're trying to bring it all
together by not hundred percent sure
that's a pretty good idea
that's just yes to get I've been alone
the sequester time what about bringing
that speck would you want to see any
vets back no I don't want to say
anything if I do I mean I'm gonna give
it well I'm gonna give it two three
weeks before I target anybody because
you never ever know but after that three
week mark I'm cutting them
okay had their chance they're gone if
there are vets that come into the house
who do you want to see Chicken George I
know there's no way that's gonna happen
um let's see who else why cuz a probably
someone from or a recent season would be
my guess
who do I like a lot I likes a Krantz
he's not coming back though um I really
really like well last year going in I
really liked Ramsay's and Kevin and then
once I kind of realized that they
weren't gonna do much we me and my whole
family jumped team Jody I'll just mean
like everybody else like everybody else
yeah I see season 18 I really like to
Bridget but I think isn't she doing tar
I don't know I don't know either I don't
know I thought speculation but she's
really cool see from 17 I really
obviously I really like Johnny Mac Jack
he was cool on that season I saw me any
one of them would be really cool but
they just got to know week four I'm
getting rid of
I'm not gonna be a friend but I like
this game can get pretty vicious yes and
pretty fast yes how vicious are you
gonna get in there for on a scale of
like Victoria to doctor will always
business I need to be okay well yes but
I think he's all good he's won more
upfront about it or like some going in
trying to seem kind of unassuming most
of my wishes will probably come out in
the diary room and in like little like
petty kind of moves as we go out okay
interesting something else that happens
every summer on this show show manses
who do you want a showmance are you
interested in a show man not gonna
happen there's no way who's gonna want
to show Mans with me I'm just like a
little guy with a squeaky voice if
someone tries the Venus showmance I mean
I want to be so suspicious like they're
gonna be up to something and like I'm
totally gonna like ward it off like
maybe I'll like not let them know I'm
super suspicious but yeah in my head red
flag red flag red flag okay so if I see
show Mansingh happens you're gonna be
super suspicious yeah not gonna trust it
100%
alright is there anything going into
this house that you're going to keep a
secret from the other houseguests not
let them well XYZ you about your
background I'm gonna be like super open
like they ask me anything I'll tell them
anything Slyke part of the thing I want
to do like I said it's like seem very
unassuming and to be that it's hard to
keep secrets I kind of want to seem
really really open like I'm not gonna go
in and like tell them how much I like to
play sports like make me a myself seem
athletic but at the same time I don't
want to not do that cuz they're gonna
see the glasses and be like token nerd
you gotta get him out of here so I mean
it's a tough tightrope to balance okay
is there anything that you're worried
about coming out about you any secrets
that are revealed okay no not even a
little bit I mean somebody's gonna do
what's gonna do okay I like it no fear
going in fully on board with the deal
you're going away for hopefully three
months hopefully what are you gonna miss
most about the outside world does anyone
not say friends and family to this if
anyone says if anyone ever sits here and
says my phone just get up and push them
off that chair because they're terrible
I've seen my friends and family I really
like spending time with them it's gonna
be super different cuz like with my
friends in my family we like we just
like roast our houseguest be like if
there's a moment of weakness with us we
just like pounce it's it we're like the
kind of family that makes fun of each
other a lot of fun same thing on my
friends be argue all the time
and Big Brother house is gonna be like
arguing throughout but there's gonna be
at first that fake niceness cuz no one
wants to be the one who falls for it so
that's gonna be kind of weird and like
tiptoe II for me but once we get through
that theoretically I'll be okay okay on
the flip side is there's something that
you're so happy to not have to deal with
for three months ah physically paying
the rent usually I have to see the money
go but like I have someone handling that
for me so I don't have to physically see
my money disappear into the landlord yes
that's true
all right why are you going to win big
brother oh I'm gonna what cuz okay so
basically I'm gonna win because like my
energy is a little gonna be infectious
you can dominate a room with energy I
think people don't realize that so my
Energy's gonna dominate any room that I
need it to and when I don't need it to
I'll be able to back off so I'm gonna be
able to add and flow as the house needs
it I already felt that energy in here
today oh I've been crushing this kind of
percent no-one's like everyone's been I
could just be like runks everyone's been
super nice to me which I'm not used to
and they could just be like that guy is
so done the second I leave but so far
who has been super super nice to me and
like complimenting me and so forth so
I'm just like a little bit of fake
confidence going on shake shallow
confident the niceness is real okay
thank you so much oh yeah you've never
been kissed huh
no I haven't liked that movie yeah what
I mean what if the first kiss goes down
and in the Big Brother house well first
I got to give you that suspicion wall
yes cuz that's that's a big wall to get
through if it happened it happens like
I'm not like planning for it I'm not
planning against it whatever happens
happens I'm very like I watch like a lot
of romantic movies so like I do have the
idea maybe built up and a pedestal in my
head a little bit okay but I mean cool
would it be to walk out of the house
with $500,000 and your first
relationship I don't know if I have the
first relationship it's gonna be super
super awkward so I'm gonna be like how
do I act in this scenario what do I do
cuz I don't know how to do that and then
I'll go home I heard the family
approached me and then her her parents
it sounds like why why we got it you're
a confident in every other area we gotta
boost the confidence in this area and
then we can lower it and everything else
everything income yes alright that's
your mission from ETD
and find some romantic confidence and
destroy the rest of it
just bring it up bring it okay to match
it yeah oh I don't like want to be like
super cocky though no just go get your
first kiss in this house okay and then I
can like and you can just test a little
bit yeah
there yeah
[Music]